laughs
hey just like hot or what's up man
you're trained to to fix a problem not
only are you trying to stop a bleeder or
fix a wound people want that pets to
look cute he's a pretty girl so when we
think plastic surgery humans we're
making the lips Fuller we're tightening
things up our plastic surgery is they
come in and they're mauled got them
pretty good what we need to do is get
these wounds cleaned up
so we're trying to make it look as
normal as we can but the pieces don't
really fit we have to make them fit and
it's almost like you made yourself a
little bit but you have to kind of like
four oh yeah but inside you like wow I
am amazed you know so those are the
words
you're looking good surgery look look
good let's bust out this joint
s
it's good to go all right
see you later
cycling between clients Dr Hodges meets
an eight-month-old Nigerian dwarf goat
who's having a wee bit of trouble hey
what's going on man so what's going on
with this gold it's falling asleep he's
falling asleep so your girlfriend here
been having some problems urinating huh
yeah
Charlie's a pet Nigerian dwarf goat I
got him when the lockdown happened I've
never had a goat in my life I just
needed company and goats are very
curious so it's like every time I go
outside I kind of learn something new
from the goat about three weeks ago I
started to notice that he was having
trouble urinating it's like trickling
out so that's when I said this could be
serious
yeah so you don't think it's anything he
ate or ingested
I want to check the ultrasound and make
sure I don't have a stoner or something
floating around here okay all right
let's go and get him some urine and do
an old sun and let's see what we got
going
with this trick on the urine it could be
a UTI which is a urinary tract infection
or it could be something a lot more
serious like a bladder stone which is
passing through the urethra so the
things that are passed out failure
actually ends up in the bloodstream and
the Animals become toxic and dies
you know
just I mean just gotta eat your pants
now hold on hey will you stop biting me
getting you in a second or second yeah
you ain't paying attention to him the
last thing I need is a hole in my pants
from a goat I need to take Charlie
outside the clinic so he can get a
little bit of fresh air and maybe eat
some grass Kelly you need to stop
because I definitely don't need them
eating up everything inside the clinic
come on over here it's okay Charlie
being able to pee is not a fun thing I'm
sure
oh goodness
Dr Hodges review is the results of
Charlie's urine test measuring for the
presence of blood in a perfect world be
yellow but we're all the way green so
we're filled with blood and we get a up
sound on the goat often times with
blockages you have to go in and you have
to correct the problem surgically so
this is a very very serious situation
but I'm hoping I can get away with
antibiotics and make this baby better
the light on
so the bladder is here damn unless you
still hurt this one's bad though
so you're blotting looks clear I don't
see anything you can see we can clean
this up let's get some antibiotics okay
good job Mr goat
I don't see any bladder stone but
Charlie definitely has bacteria and
blood in his urine and also in the
bladder hopefully with antibiotics we
can get rid of it and he's back to
eating grass and just bad and doing his
thing
[Music]
he does have a UTI which is basically a
infected bladder I'm gonna give him a
shot and then one for pain one and a box
I'm very confident that we're going to
get this problem fixed
it's good to know that it was just a UTI
not kidney stones now I'm just gonna
monitor him more I'm learning so
whatever happens with Charlie he's part
of my family so I'm going to take care
of him
[Music]
cups of chicken you gonna be okay doc
I'm sure everything will be fine how are
you doing
all right all right look at the baby got
multiple babies in here huh
this is Charlotte it's okay
so I brought my chick Charlotte she is
about three weeks old the only thing we
have in our farmers are chickens and
she's one of my favorites we noticed
that Charlotte's eye was yucky looking
and she also had a few pet marks on her
back these chickens are my life so I
just want to make sure that everything's
okay with her so what's going on
somebody pecked her eye and we think
it's the chicken that's in the cage with
her but then she also has a spot on her
back is the other chick being mean she
might be okay all right this probably
was a little chicken
we did have another chick that passed
away we think the respiratory infection
have you seen any different kind of
respiration any other the babies start
sneezing anything then the other baby
were sneezing I want to do a couple
things here okay we're going to put a
stain in it uh to determine if there's a
scratch on it I may also try to get an
x-ray it makes you a longer than
everything look good there and that's
going to determine how we treat this
thing as well okay all right
hearing that this chick has been
attacked but it also has respiratory
infection so I want to know if their two
are associated but in this case we won't
know anything until we do further
Diagnostics we need to take X-rays then
because we have trauma to the eye one
thing that I don't want to do is what we
call a floor scene stain test you are so
cute yes all right let's see if we can
get a little drop of stain here once I
put the stain in there's a scratch it
will collect in that crater then it'll
fluoresce and that'll tell me that we
have a scratch or an abrasion or
something on the cornea
well don't go in one drop one buddy
all right so now we're going to flip the
light off and see if we got something
going on here Jordan
he's collecting around the bottom but I
don't see it on itself so as I look at
the stain there's no uptake on the eye
but I do see some conjunctiviters which
makes me think that this may be
associated with the respiratory disease
okay she's infected now yeah we
definitely got to put meds in there here
let's see if we can get X-ray hey you're
not scared of one of the small dots oh
no they can't hurt me now when they get
older they get bad and mean so my fear
of chicken stem from when I was young I
was picked by a chicken when I was
little and ever since then it's been a
little touch and go for me I need to go
and get you up while you're young
always be nice to Dr Ferguson
don't be like all the other chickens
it looks like she's legit listening okay
thank you because all the other chickens
they don't like me always be nice to Dr
Ferguson
all right
okay cool everything good
I think we're seeing eye to eye now you
know I think this hypnotism is kind of
working a little bit and I actually told
make sure you tell all your friends to
be nice to Dr Ferguson no matter what my
issues are with chickens I'm gonna do
the best I can to take care of all of
them no matter what their ancestor did
to me I'm looking at the long areas here
they look nice and dark so I don't see
where there's any pneumonia or anything
like that we look pretty good here now
we need to address that area on the back
well luck is a little trauma apart from
the other chick let's clean that up a
little bit
yeah it's all right
girl
okay
this is the proud moment I'm one with
the chicken
so after looking at these wounds it
looks like it probably did come from his
sibling don't let big brother or sister
jump on you anymore
and that's right luckily we're just
dealing with conjunctivitis in the eye
we should be back to New in a few days
all right mom there's no scratch or
anything on the cornea but there's
definitely a lot of inflammation and
conjunctivitis this area on the back
probably coming from the other baby kind
of being a little tough gonna send a
general antibiotic home with you and
we're gonna sense of ointment for the
eyes okay all right both of them twice a
day Dr Ferguson hit the nail on the head
and did a really good job with us helped
explain things where we could understand
it you know if you get all the talk we
had in the back okay very thankful that
he helped us out with Charlotte you take
care of this baby okay okay all right
thank you y'all have a good one okay you
too
among the ebb and flow of patients is a
six-year-old Australian Shepherd who got
into a bad scuffle hey
hello how are you good
so we got a little dog fight two kids
got her what
my dog's name is Shea she got attacked
by my neighbors two pit bull dogs she's
very very smart very active loving
wanting to be by my side all the time
she's my shadow they just came out of
nowhere they've got her through the
fence they had her pow and then they had
her mouth and I had to literally beat
him on the head I'm sure for a while for
them to let go and I kept thinking in my
head they're not gonna let go they're
going to kill her I think the only
reason they let her go is in that flesh
tour what
all right come around here
it is all the way down in there it's
cold there there's a hole between it's
torn all the way down to the jump
I'm gonna clean it up let's do some
fluids get some pain medicine and then
I'm gonna try to see if I can suture
this and get it to hold but I'm gonna
want to shoot an x-ray also because I
can feel a little bit of possibly Broken
Sound
I'm gonna cry now okay no I'm gonna make
this bill I'm gonna make it better it's
okay we're gonna take it back Mom and
try to get it cleaned up okay
okay
I know he's gonna do his best
the thought that you keep me fixed
it would be devastating
I wish that it had never happened
[Music]
can I open
can I open I know
all right the problem I mean this whole
jaw is literally torn apart I'm gonna
see if we have a fracture which is going
to open up a whole another can of worms
if this jar is broken I would have to
somehow plate this jaw together trying
to keep a moving joint together is very
difficult also you gotta think about
food when the dog eats getting food into
the bone it can give osteomyelitis it
was basically infection in the bone and
that can be fatal get my x-rays ready
let's get on the table please this is
about as bad as you can get if I can't
repair this y'all this dog might not be
able to eat the job can get infected and
it's oftentimes fatal and ultimately
when you might not be able to save this
though
[Music]
and all of this is soft tissue that has
just been torn away from the body Shea
the Australian Shepherd is in x-ray to
determine if her jaw is broken so
it's just a tange of good news
the bone of the jaw luckily they didn't
shred that oh thank you Lord but the
actual Jawbone itself seems to be intact
I just want to look it up now all of
this stuff hanging you see this fluid
that is fluid that's hanging this is the
jaw somehow I got to figure out how to
get this attack back to here and stay
let me show you in real life what I mean
come on over
so my issue comes to
this is attached here it's almost like
plastic surgery I got to get this to
stay but the problem is there's nothing
to attach because there's no skin on
this side oh my God it's gonna be all
right
take good care of course I got you I
know you are yes ma'am I'll figure it
out
all right Mama we're going to give you a
call to update you after surgery we got
to get this fixed if I can't get this
back together this dog probably won't
survive so my plan is surgery is
actually to go in and try to find as
much healthy tissue as I can that
brought it try to get it to bleed so
that I know that it's healthy and try to
real test it and hope this works we're
gonna see how good you being a plastic
surgeon is
um we'll see all right
since there's no actual tissue still
left on the bone I mean the bone is
clean my plan is to bring the lip up and
try to suture it up under the gum line
between the teeth and see if I can
actually get that to hold there's no way
for me to tie for this job to that job
on so so I'm trying to tie it down
underneath to give me some support
because someone would work with whatever
little kiss I have and make some magic
I just need one last piece so I can get
in here
all right
thank you thank you thank you
I think it was pretty good dark really I
tried to make a gum line so I started at
the bottom cleaned it tacked it down
tagged it down here
so hopefully if this stays and stays
tight it'll look just like a normal doll
now let's see if I can get it home I'm
really concerned if it's gonna hold
because there could be some dead tissue
still and if there's no blood supply
it's gonna get in the crowded and it's
gonna fail I'm just hoping and praying
for the best and in time we'll see what
happens
[Music]
oh oh oh she got some snot out
they brought in Bibble she's our guinea
pig she's a year and a half old this
morning when I woke up one of the first
things I could hear was her breathing it
was louder and sounded more painful than
before and it was very concerning you're
okay Bibble is she okay hi hey how y'all
doing good so what we got going on here
she had a cough she was labored
breathing earlier she's been eating okay
not today yeah not today this is so not
like
never stays
so first of all we need to take an x-ray
determine with these lungs look like and
that'll help us determine whether we
have a upper respiratory infection or
like pneumonia in the lungs okay it can
be pretty cereal
all right
okay yeah I'm fine
so what I want to do first is take an
x-ray and see where we are then we'll
see what our plan is for you okay okay
also I'd say watch your finger just in
case yes she nibbles Bibble presented
with respiratory issues with breathing
I'm really concerned that we're dealing
with something like pneumonia it can be
deadly in these guinea pigs
this is our first x-ray we took so
mostly in your lungs is mostly air so it
should be dark we look in this spot here
it looks pretty white up there so what
that tells me we do have a little
pneumonia
so treatment-wise we do a couple things
one is antibiotics okay two we're gonna
go on some anti-inflammatory with this
medication hopefully make it feel better
if things change and we get worse during
this period of time you need to get back
in I really feel like a medication that
bill is going to pull through we're
going to get all this mixed up for you
we'll come back in in just a second okay
thank you
nibbler
luckily Bilbo got in today had it waited
a day or two it may have succumb to
pneumonia you were right we like to
nibble don't we yeah
all right
once a day it goes in the refrigerator
okay we got our antibiotics here mama
this is Apple and watermelon flavor
she said what did that taste like
now listen let me give you some
instructions here you have to get well
and feel better today getting a little
bit better tomorrow then I need you back
to full strength is that a bit is that
okay
there you go okay all right all right if
I knew when we were gonna walk out
you're gonna hear some news about her
that we weren't going to want to hear
but I'm hoping we can get her you know
healthy again I'll probably be the one
that stays up late make sure she's still
breathing okay she's kind of delicate
right now I'm gonna have to keep an eye
on her don't let you go about the moment
I'll take care of the baby okay let's
keep it posted if you need us give us a
call okay
Dr Hodges in surgery Tech Paul are
Fielding a call from a local
University's agricultural research
department so you don't leave it
um I don't really prefer it I like fish
all kinds of fish fish sandwiches
tacos fishing grits one of my
specialties I like to cook salmon oh
yeah you know what I take that back I
love salmon croquette okay from the can
right so you think just cause that
salmon is in a can it just come from the
fish factory yeah wait no whatever helps
you sleep at night I got you can I look
at some of that canned fish
the catfish he don't like the real fish
with biscuits
so we're in Fort Valley State University
my alma mater they call me near having a
fish problem I've Loved fish since I was
a little boy I actually graduated with a
degree in Fisheries biology I'm a fish
guy so I'm here to help them solve that
problem how are you good what's going on
well for the past three months I've been
noticing that my tilapia have been dying
I'm a fish assistant at the Fort Valley
aquaculture center right now we're
focusing on breeding tactics for the
fish I put some new tilapia inside of a
tank and I noticed them jumping out and
they have a loss of appetite so I was
wondering if you could figure out what
the problem was
I need to make sure that my babies are
okay so hopefully he could fix the
problem these are my babies
this don't too bad but I definitely see
them trying to scrub themselves on the
bottom and circling around a little
write it so you got something that died
I got it right over here for you
all right see this white in the view so
fish need gives the breed yes and when
they start getting this white
proliferation here
bad news so what do you think it's
parasites these things are microscopic
you can't really see it but I knew it
was some kind of parasite my job was to
figure out exactly which one because of
these little boogers they're deadly all
right father I'm gonna catch a fresh
fish get a piece of the gills I'm gonna
go ahead and set me up a wet slide
slide right here
[Music]
it's gonna be my fish
ing all right so you're gonna be my
guinea pig
there you go all right I'm gonna take
just a little piece to the gills for my
wet prep wet preparation is a diagnostic
technique where a small tissue sample is
taken and checked for signs of specific
disease
this does not look good your fish has
something called trickle dinner
when you have a few it's okay
but when you get a microscope full
that's a problem what happened is the
parasites attach themselves to the gills
the fish can barely breathe so this type
of parasite become a real heavy burden
on the fish especially when you got a
lot in close quarters that prayer site
can run rampant and you could just have
a pool of dead fish
you got these tanks and then you have
one back here that circulates as well
yes
these two circulate together which also
connects to all these so one fish has
pretty sure all these fish has and if
all these fish in here got this
and they all made up this does not look
good
oh boy Fort Valley needs these fish for
research so we got to make sure they do
okay anyway fishy fishy Dr Hodges
discovers a deadly parasite at the
University's Aquatic Research facility
we gotta get in this face let's go look
at the ones in the big tank
so in the big tank these are also
tilapia and I am sure there are
thousands of fish in there the reason I
want to check these guys out is water
it's in the circulating so if these guys
have triggered in them we got a real
problem I gotta get some of these fish
if you need help let me know
this ain't gonna work you can barely
reach the bottom
everybody kisses you know what just get
my waders oh here you go sir here you go
unless you're gonna jump in there and
grab them you got your weight it's right
here come out here you tell him I had to
get in it's a surprise they're not
planning to go swimming look at them
well Dr Ferguson when I need him
all right who's gonna be first come on
man Paul you ready ready
you got the fish
you wearing my bucket
my name is Hodges are you ready I got
three you got three oh you put the
waiters on voila we have fish pretty
good I just stand up a whole lot of
school for a long time to learn that all
right boss
see what we got
oh boy this fish is more covered I know
you see the same thing same thing I was
hoping it was just gonna be isolated to
that one so with the circulation all of
them got it so all of them got to be
treated and it's all bad
these fish probably wouldn't have been
with us in the next week or two I'm
gonna fix as long as my picture are okay
there's a game plan formula is the
treatment for trigger Daniels a good way
to go formalin usually works so you have
your sick tank so you just gonna
transfer them to a little sick tank I
want you to put some in this one since
it's his own unique circulation and then
we're gonna use this one
treat them
and we're gonna get this thing fixed up
these organisms have to live on the fish
so once we get those taken care of then
we can put them back in the maintain all
right right
so we gotta get this formula action
going all right I know you hear about
formula from out this stuff that we
usually put dead tissue in but I ain't
gonna kill your face don't worry I trust
you I promise formalin is deadly so you
got to use the exact amount of formula
or you can kill the fish along with the
parasite come on up here come on look at
the step what do I do so just kind of
fill it up Paul's gonna give me my
formula we put it in and we're gonna
treat some fish how long does it take
for the parasite to go away I was
thinking the next few days formula does
the trick
we're gonna have these guys ready for
research and Fort Valley are going to be
straight to the top it was really scary
I was very concerned but as soon as she
told me you could fix it I felt much
better I really do appreciate Dr Hyde it
was glad that he can come in and help me
really diagnose it and fix it thought I
had to use the best
why not not one of the best for my fish
thank you so much no problem at all
foreign
[Music]
Dr Ferguson came to the aid of Charlotte
the silky chicken there's definitely a
lot of inflammation and conjunctivitis
we're going to send a general antibiotic
home with you and we're going to send
some ointment for the eye now after a
little home care and a lot of TLC this
hand can see the world clearly again
Charlotte is doing wonderful we love her
so much she has recovered fully now her
eyes looks much better and she's grown a
lot since we've took her to chiropractor
her feathers are growing back if we
wouldn't have gone her on antibiotics
like we did probably wouldn't have made
it and we really love her we're so
thankful for what Dr Ferguson did for us
thank you Dr person and chiropractor for
[Music]
the next one
so all our bottles and all as far as
infection we look good
but it's always a book right Dr Hodges
is on the phone with shea the Australian
Shepherd's owner to give an update on
the post-surgery status of her dog
so where the tissue was crushed up under
like it's literally black and dying
there's no blood supply so it's start to
Die part of it healed but the part
that's dying I'm gonna have to redo oh
no I know
so we gotta do something we ain't gonna
give up okay I was worried about more
tissue dying and it has so it caused my
suture line to fail because dead stuffed
on Hill I mean I'm kind of at a dead end
here because I gotta somehow get this to
hold and get that good tissue to hang in
there with me
how am I gonna close this one
look at that all that tissue is dead
gosh you don't even feel it just dead
man Dr Hodges is working on a plan to
save Shea the Australian Shepherd's lip
and life I'm literally gonna try to pull
a rabbit out of a hat to save Shay's
life I gotta think out of the box I'm
always reading about different tactics
and my fish is the Fort Valley State
University actually made me think I'm
gonna try a trick and see if I can get
that area to hold using tilapia skin
tilapia has been used in many many types
of experimental approaches as far as
Skin grafts so I made a call down there
and I was like I definitely could use
some fresh tilapia in my bag of tricks
and they weren't the ones that were sick
do I know how to skin it no
I know I eat it first thing you have to
do is Harvest your skins and get them
cleaned up so just keep rubbing it and
it'll okay tilapia skin provides
collagen and elasticity as well as
properties that stop
it's gonna work but I think it's Shay's
only hope all right let's go to work
just a Hail Mary if this don't work
either euthanize this dope oh this is
nasty it's super infectious it's seeping
you've got dead tissue that I'm gonna
deprive put it back together then hope
it holds to the jaw then put my suture
bandage of fish skin to bring collagens
and all the different things we have so
I don't know what's gonna happen but
it's got to be the perfect storm
everything has to work all right
go ahead and put your tilapia skins
right here
let's go for it it's gonna work
all right let's try this piece here
they teach all this in good school
though I read about it they do this with
people all the time if you think of it
it's almost like baking a cake so I'm
bringing the jar together and I'm baking
my cake tilapia service is my ice but
it's the icing that makes it look great
what I'm talking about oh yeah part fish
part dog what you call that doggies yeah
that is awesome man we'll see we're
gonna see it gonna work
ain't gonna see it gonna work sometimes
it's good to have some assurance that
you're doing it right you just need a
chili to be like right right right so
it's always great it's darkest now
it's beautiful and darkish for sure are
you a good chili thank you man
hoping this holes I'm hoping I get a
sealed I've tried to bring all the blood
supply can not perfect by any means but
there's no choice
I guess it's gonna have to do oh good
though surgery is done you know this
fish may feel a little weird with a
little tightness but I mean considering
Jaws hanging almost off I mean I'm sure
this is definitely feeling better but I
needed this steak my ideal thing would
be for this to start granulating and
healing while my fish skin dries and
forms the scab on top so nothing can
penetrate in we have the protection and
hopefully we do fine time will tell
all right
all right on the road again the team is
heading to Nicole's animal rescue Farm
to treat some ferocious new arrivals
who's ready to get bit by alligators
but what about the most important
question and what's the most important
question how big is it
that's for you you don't let it know I'm
gonna be the one who live to tell the
story
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's going on what's up how you doing
today great Dr Hodges and Dr Ferguson
are coming out to check out my rescue
alligators I got three wimpy is my
eight-footer Godzilla and my alligator
road rash that I'm mainly concerned
about has a bad back left leg so I'm
asking them if it's fixable or not the
big question is what's the plan on
getting them out we had to take each out
individually okay and then I'm gonna
have you guys hold them whoa whoa we're
gonna do this this is it yep at least
mine is bigger than yours let's go
that'll make me feel better just a
little like some tape you headed to
third grade to do your project well see
I had a larger take because she knew I
was going to be the most courageous one
to go and take care of them out nowhere
in my Veterinary application process did
they say I'm gonna have to go move some
alligators out of pen because I'm kind
of bite-sized
this one is Godzilla Godzilla
got your tape ready buddy
go that rope is going to come off hold
on hold on hold on okay hold on I'm just
gonna get him what he's his injury back
here it was filled with maggots and I
can smell an infection hopefully we can
fix him up so he can be released Dr
Ferguson if you want to spot his tail he
doesn't
oh yeah he's a big boy
any idea what happened to him this one
was near a neighborhood probably fencing
maybe climbing underneath the fences all
right so we definitely got a nice one
pretty deep down here so we're going to
start some antibiotics we're going to
clean this thing out we've got one area
up front look like a abscess will that
open initially yes sir some cream on
this one it'll get smaller and smaller
the air that you put the ointment in
you're almost done but so do you think
that I'll be able to release this yeah I
think this will be fine to release so it
may take at least two or three weeks all
right about to get antibiotics on board
and you will be good to go good job
Godzilla
can y'all make alligator noises
I don't know can we
no should it sound good that was more
sneakers huh there you go do not catch
any alligators in your future so what's
the greater call like oh it was all
alone that's a baby alligator so when
you make a baby gator call they all come
okay
good job
all right let's get a little wimpy all
right with this big one that we're
fixing to get out she rolls she does the
death roll and she's almost eight feet
but if she rolls it we'll take us okay
it'll take all three well Nicole give
the warning we better take heed of it
death row stuff
so the alligator
start rolling and then start rolling
once they start rolling it's going to be
pretty difficult to restrain to that
point I don't want to be an internet
sensation let's hope that's not the case
just before we go in I want to tell you
something brother I love you man
I love you back thank you let's make it
happen all right
it looks so wimpy though there you go I
think it's working come on
all right
oh all right all right all right keep
her head that way
no no no no no
[Music]
the docs are at Nicole's Farm to give
medical attention to some very unwilling
candidates
[Music]
oh I sure will it's a strong animal my
friend yo wrap your hand here
you got it
she's heavy itchy
all right y'all got him you saw that
death row we don't want that to happen
again at all all right let's go yeah I
know y'all can't work out ladies
you got to exam this time I'm holding it
we got some abrasions on there now she
got two missing teeth that she broke out
okay I don't know if it needs anything
else but smell her breath see if it's
infected is it yummy not too bad is that
you always
sweet it's sweet it's me oh you sure I
don't think you should be joking me
while I'm holding alligator and keeping
you protecting me fair enough you do
smell better than Elegance
it looks good we got some superficial
abrasions I'm just gonna give an
antibiotic injection all right whip it
we'll go ahead and let her heal and then
she should be ready to go back into the
wild now we have the one that I'm
worried about all right all right has a
bad foot which leg is it I want to see a
little fun this one right here left rear
yes sir oh yeah that would be horrible I
know this leg is much bigger than others
it's a lot larger so something's going
on there alligator with a fractured leg
is gonna be in a whole lot of trouble
alligator that can't run it's in bad
shape I'm Really Gonna even get prey
what you feel about that boss man
definitely more swelling in here I just
want to come see what kind of
neurological response we get all right
all right so we got knee pain yeah yeah
it does have deep pain that's good news
that is great news I'm kind of pinching
let's see if there's any kind of deep
pain and we do have quite a bit here we
start to move here not so much I'm
getting deep pain in some areas but I'm
not really getting much teeth pain in
the other so I'm really concerned you
know a lot of times that tell me that we
have an injury the nerve is not
functioning with the muscle and we're
not able to move this leg and in that
case we'll just drag it it's working
even a fracture I think we have is
comparing the two yeah is a fracture
there's movement like a fresh fracture
but there's more bone development here
so I think there's a lot of swelling
right pressure on the nerve that's
causing the nerve deficit and when we
can get that to subside then we regain
function if it's a fracture is it
fixable one thing we talk about in
veterinary medicine if we can get bones
to touch they'll heal but we have to
make sure that we don't keep pushing on
it though because the more the bearing
of the waste the better chance of this
thing that Hill we're gonna try
confinement in a smaller area so we
don't have to move in place on it okay
we'll do
so we're building an enclosure so Road
Rash can have a very minimum amount of
room and still have water I'm actually
hopeful that this is going to work so
we'll see we'll see if you all right
thanks guys
[Music]
got a snake like this in route yeah
right here you got a lead in your pocket
Dr Ferguson receives an emergency case
of a German Shepherd bitten by a snake
how long ago we got bit
um
it was a copperhead I'm pretty sure if
that helps oh yeah let's get her inside
all right you can come on in sir the
copperhead is one of six venomous snake
species found in Georgia it's bite can
be deadly they would go
got a dog get a snake we think it's a
copperhead let's get an event I'm on the
board all right it's all right y'all
send me Paul please it's okay all right
it's all right
Venom called a lot of swelling a lot of
inflammation but overall it caused
issues with bleeding internally these
guys can either bleed to death or
neurological they have issues and it can
result in paralysis and death what you
need that we need one y'all to hold up
so we can try to kill the Catherine
because you're pretty fractious okay
give me some anti-venom yeah I'll get on
board snake bites can be time sensitive
because we only have a small window that
we can give any Venom and it's going to
work for us so we need to get this
anti-venom on board right away I heard
her outside kind of jumping around and
like I walked outside and saw it curled
up already I guess so yeah grabbed her
up and put her you know inside the house
when they get this toxin you're gonna
start vomiting they made diarrhea all
the other different signs hopefully we
got the baby in turn to get this
interview
if you don't take long for that swelling
to start there
[Music]
I appreciate it man what the Anna venom
does it kind of binds to the Venom and
it basically eliminates it from the body
all right here we go girl it's okay it's
okay sweetie it's okay it's all right
it's important that the dog stays calm
because there are things we need to do
we need to get a Catherine we need to
get medication on board and it makes it
a lot more difficult when you have an
anxious dog
roll there gotta get you to calm down
the Critter fixers are on a Race Against
Time to treat Layla the German Shepherds
poisonous snake bite right here behind
you boss ready to go appreciate it bro
all right good luck bro
that is going to survive if it's a
venomous snake so we need to get this
Janet Venom on board it's all right baby
good job guys all right let's get a
heart rate she's usually predation like
this yeah she's pretty um excited yeah
all the time all right
she's like two and a half so I'm still
like still looks like her hair yeah
we're gonna get you all right baby adult
snakes sometimes just do like a drive
right that's not a drive-by oh no no no
it's causing some issues there you know
you know it's folding pretty good though
so you just wanted to play then that's
all you want to do just play with the
snake then you got to let this stuff
work in Magic so we've given the anime
Venom this Venom could be inside causing
a whole lot of damage it's a wait and
see now hopefully the end event works
for us we gave her some
anti-inflammatory to help with the
swelling in regard to any Venom so it's
not just kind of waiting watch kind of
thing okay what's their odds of being
young okay right now I'm feeling okay
about it because you got her in pretty
quick but we're not out of the woods yet
yes sir
[Music]
come to work and the first thing I would
do is make a beeline and Shay's case
because I want to see if there's tilapia
skin grab on the shade y'all it's
actually hold them let's see what you're
looking like this morning as far as
forming a good Tight Seal I just need
you to stay in place I fish still seems
to be working I see red tissue which is
good oh man look at that my fish is
still holding here it might hold
filter you are a whole different dog
that bandage will eventually fall off
it's just amazing her temperament I mean
look at it I hope this level just can't
work let's see
and it healed up nice
wow I first did his job look at that
drawing it is come back we can see the
teeth it doesn't hurt that is nice and
pink and holding very well you're a
great plastic surgery
I'm ecstatic so I feel like I can sense
stay home today and look like the
tilapia did his trick yeah yeah
dog park fish now right hey that tilapia
helps save this dog's life
that is what we want so we good all
right oh thank you oh my god thank you
you were the best such a relief and such
joy that she's going home I'm so
grateful for Dr Hodges all they did it's
unbelievable don't definitely cherish
every moment y'all good to go thank you
love you so much
no problem see y'all later isn't that
amazing Paul I'm telling you so after
the weeks of hoping that I can make shea
better to unite say with Brenda and to
see both of them playing it makes it all
worth it it's why I became a
veterinarian and why I actually think
this is the greatest profession in the
world it just is an amazing experience
let's go home
yay say you're free
[Music]
at least the snake bite is
joint look at you you're looking good no
that's it she said I'm ready licking
your face is going down that was a close
call Layla and she's doing much better
all the swelling and faces going down
she seems to have an appetite so it
seems like those fluids and anter Venom
work great
[Music]
looking real good
what's up man looking good
did you have a fun snake I never found
it though it's
comprehensive the worst and they are
meat they don't back down the big ones
they usually try to split away I lived
out the country for like two years and
yeah she never got bit and now that I
moved here to the city now
thank you all right
playlist is really really lucky I'm glad
that her owner saw it we're able to get
her in the nickel time everything is
going to be fine just away from those
snakes
[Music]
it's all right buddy you hear something
a little bit
Nicole arrives with road rash the
alligator to find out if his leg has
been healing let's see what we got
nature it actually looks better am I
looking at the bone the swelling's down
yeah it looks a lot better I mean much
better I don't want to see how you walk
where are you taking my baby
[Music]
come on
you want to say hi clamps and walk
[Music]
IES
well you can tell it's a lot less
sweaters on last time much better that's
sweet that's what I want to say oh man
take this alligator out put them on the
ground any plants hey I see him hey it's
doing good I mean no more Dragon he's
actually walking around I don't know if
I've ever been happier let's see an
alligator walk Nicole yeah I took him
outside it looks great he is literally
planting on that so he's doing very well
good news that's awesome so I said let's
let them keep them caves rest another
couple months he'll be ready to go thank
you so much that's good
Dr Hodges showed me that road rash's leg
is improving it's really good news I
love having the alligators but it's so
much better for them to be able to live
in the wild so I'm going to keep doing
what he said and we're on the right
track see y'all later see y'all later
Nicole keeping this alligator confined
and actually just letting Mother Nature
do her job yeah man it's like his hip
I'm super excited I mean it's amazing
thank you
[Music]